you don't think of
accomplishing
things but
you also subconsciously
you you work for the things you really
believe in that was our final et sit
down with betty who was 94 years young
at the time
one of her final appearances was at the
2018 emmys where she got a standing
ovation from the star-studded crowd when
she was 96.
you can stay in a in a career this long
and still have
people put up with you
bt was with betty for decades and we
always marveled at her enthusiasm and
energy
you are a woman who loves to work what
is it that makes you want to come to
work every single day oh i just love i'm
so lucky to be in this business i never
take it for granted at my age i should
have been thrown out a long time ago but
i
i love to work you work with the nicest
people in the world
and they take such good care of you
you are the most remarkable woman in the
business who
no
i'm the luckiest old brother in the
business to when you figure i'm still
working at this age working well into
her 90s she once gave us the secret to
her longevity i love a cocktail i love i
love peanut butter and jelly and stuff
but i don't abuse
the things that that i know if if you're
blessed with this good health you should
take advantage of it are you ever going
to retire no of course not i don't think
so why
betty was an eight-time emmy winner
she picked up her first two statuettes
as the flirtatious tv homemaker sue ann
nivens on the mary tyler moore show to
the most voluptuous exciting desirable
creature on god's earth
she was the neighborhood nymphomaniac
that's right but she was a good home
economist the thing was it was all in
her own mind betty solidified her tv
legend status with her role as the ditzy
senior citizen rosen island on the
golden girls my father told stan that he
had to marry me i was pregnant
you had a blow gun wedding
these aren't old people they you don't
self-destruct once you pass 55. we're
all just as as vital and sensual and and
uh
nutty and good and bad as anybody else i
don't want to spoil a surprise but in a
couple of weeks someone in this room is
going to know how to yodel
well this season we're writing the other
girls out and rose is doing it in one
it's just going to be you know the betty
white show and then
sorry about that no that's the real
betty coming forward you see rose has
disappeared
the show would bring her her third emmy
but betty accepted it on behalf of all
her golden girls co-stars i am the lucky
one who gets to come up and pick up this
beautiful golden girl
but
estelle and rue and b and i all thank
you we're a match set you can't split us
up while many considered betty to be
america's grandma she had no children of
her own animals were her babies in fact
our very first interview with her was in
an animal shelter where she shared the
spotlight with a testy morris the cat
he's not too thrilled with these kittens
or the my thrill with the mic
morris i know you're a star but you're
forgetting your roots she once told us
she was not afraid of death but thought
of it in her own special very betty way
it's lovely to think
there is something we don't know
and
as as a human race we have learned so
much and we've gained so much knowledge
but that's something
nobody knows what happens afterwards
it's a secret
[Music]